let's read the latest update on the
great honking
the guardian reports ottawa police are
considering military intervention to end
unlawful blockade authorities warned
bringing in the military carried a
massive risk as they believed the
protesters are armed what's really
really fascinating about this
let me read this paragraph the ottawa
police chief peter slowly warned on
wednesday that officers did not have the
resources to remove a fleet of trucks
parked by the protesters in the national
capital adding the city was considering
requesting help from canadian armed
forces what did we say yesterday
we said even if they wanted to the
police would not have the means to
remove these trucks and if some of these
trucks are just like just driving my
truck what can you do about it the truck
the tow truck companies reportedly are
refusing to get involved they've said
you know various companies have reported
as saying we have
agreements within the community we don't
want to get involved in whatever this is
but the protests and the government
stuff leave us out of it so you
basically have these truckers in ottawa
along with a bunch of other cars wailing
their horns
and there's nothing the government can
do to stop it the military won't be able
to tow anybody the truckers are here to
stay and uh it's really really simple if
if the people of of uh ottawa
if the government wants it to stop
just comply
if you just comply you'll get your city
back it's not hard it's only two weeks
of honking to restore the freedoms oh i
love it yeah i mean there is just
something so beautiful and satisfying
about seeing the worst
most controlling group of people you've
ever seen in your life not being able to
force their will onto a group of people
it's like they finally found something
they couldn't get past and it's glorious
you know you know i was thinking about
this is video of a guy and he's yelling
i haven't been able to sleep in five
days because of the honking
and i was like
i literally don't care about you guy you
sat back
while the government steamrolled by
decree all of this awful stuff that
caused strife and cast in people's lives
and destroyed their businesses
and now people are honking their horns
the only reason this guy is yelling is
because he thinks he has a right to tell
them to stop
you see he didn't he didn't do anything
to stop the government from steamrolling
over people's rights no but now he's
going to go to a trucker and be like
i'll i'll yell at you sorry buddy you've
got the workers rising up and saying no
if you if you wouldn't stand up for your
rights then what do you think you're
going to get accomplished look
it's just it's remarkable that
the you you can clearly see the the
dynamics of the political landscape here
the government can do it he won't
complain he says what freedoms have you
even lost
but when the people stand up and create
discomfort now he's mad you know what go
lick a boot dude i don't i don't care to
hear it i'm thinking about the uh at the
end of world war ii when the americans
and the british were rolling through
germany and liberating the all the i
mentioned this once before on the show
all the german citizens that had just
been sitting standing by and watching it
happen were now getting basically
conscripted out of their houses to go
clean up the hot the concentration camps
and forced to look at it with their own
eyes and see what this is what they've
done they weren't in an up they weren't
in a position to tell the american
troops stop honking because it was it
was had gone that far we haven't gone
that far yet and hopefully we won't but
you can't sit by and comply with the
tyrannical government and expect when
the cavalry comes in to fix the
situation that you're not going to be
pulled into it yeah well said also can
you believe being like i understand it's
a little frustrating to have people
honking your horns but it's like oh my
goodness the people who bring me all of
my food and literally everything i need
to survive without complaining every
single day are making noise when i want
to sleep one time in my entire life i'm
so sorry that that happened to you
exactly sympathetic yes yeah yeah yeah
you know what man the honking will
continue until freedom improves i like
that i i
i would be opening my window and and
cheering
yeah
what's interesting is the ruling class
now being exposed for the contempt that
they have for the common man it used to
be
even republicans here democrats
obviously standing for working class
individuals and
them collectively but now they can't
even hide their contempt they can't even
hide their contempt for
who hillary clinton called the
deplorables and now justin trudeau who
won't even deign to meet with these
people saying he doesn't agree with them
like he did the blm protesters so you
just have this global contempt of the
ruling elite finally fully exposed for
hating the people that they're supposed
to protect and defend and i think that
that that's sort of what happened um you
know on january 6 same thing oh yeah
yeah you know what really really blew my
mind as i was browsing reddit about an
hour or so ago and there was a post
where it said something like oh yeah it
was in in ottawa someone put in their
window it said you know nazis f off and
there's like a swastika with a line
through it
and then i i saw that and it's a top
post and i was like jeez they are laying
on the prop again it's so boring but i
look i looked at the comments and the
comments on reddit it's always leftists
being like
right
no the comments were people saying like
there was one guy like this is so dumb
like you know people were saying like
look i get the honkings annoying but it
was literally one guy with a flag
seriously and then someone else was like
yeah but what about the confederate flag
and then all the responses were like we
watched them throw that guy out of the
protest
propaganda's not working i mean we'll
get into it later but cnn just
completely imploding no it's if you do
if you can't propagandize a bunch of
redditors and get them to accept the
narrative no homework there's nothing
there's nothing no because
reddit is
such an easily astroturfed platform that
i'm pretty sure
like if you're going to ask me based on
what i know about marketing and what's
going on with the social media platforms
i'd be willing to bet
and we do know this is true to a certain
extent
reddit is basically just political
organizations manipulating the platform
to create the perception of popular
opinion and republicans are really bad
at it so they don't and the democrats
are much better at it and big tech works
with them and colludes with them so you
go on reddit man all of the top posts
are like socialists communists far left
everything
it is mind numbing but when even that
stuff isn't working
you've how do you how do you
propagandize people that you're the
workers that you're standing up for the
poor people when it's truckers
non-college educated you know for the
most part people who are just working
class jobs who are bringing let's jam
and say bringing you your food and
they're the bad guys i don't think that
narrative is going to fly so do you
think it's safe to say that they believe
obviously that the next step after
propaganda is to bring in the military
because that's what it looks like to me
remember we were talking about was it
the tales of the economic hitman or
whatever that book was called yeah was
that what was called ian uh economic hit
man yes like tail like it wasn't tails
but something like that it was like the
store like stories or you know something
like confessions was it confessions of
an academic hitman yeah he basically
said that and i'm going to butcher this
but it's something like
first they come to you and ask you to
like be on their side you reject them
then they come back and say how about
some money then you reject them then
they kill you
or something what they'll do is they
come in they try and bribe you to join
their side if you say no then they try
and assassinate you and if they can't
then they should be a full-scale
military yeah
so this seems to be like where we're at
right first they try propagandizing it's
not the exact same thing that doesn't
work now they're trying to organize
counter protests yeah but and they're
already talking about bringing in the
military you'll see they'll probably
single out an individual in the trucker
convoy and then start propagandizing him
because then they're now they're going
to do the ad hominem attack now they did
that oh they did they did that it didn't
work
yeah so first they smear the whole event
oh they're a bunch of far right racists
then we started seeing posts about like
this organizer is far right and
associated with the alt-right and blah
blah blah nobody cared it's getting
bigger it's get the honking grows the
honking continues until freedom improves
now they're talking about military well
and this is what i think happens they've
overplayed their hand to the point where
everyone who sees the propaganda knows
that it's ridiculous and they don't get
that back that's the wonderful part
about it once you overplay your hand
like it's not like you get the cards
back people are just never gonna trust
them when they talk about anything ever
again and it's beautiful this is about
so much more than just truckers right
and everyone knows that it has been from
the beginning they're asserting their
rights as workers and so it extends to
all other people and all their fields
that are necessary but also they're
really standing up for the ordinary
person
of the the nation they're from and i
think other nations as well and they're
also making it perfectly clear that the
average person does not accept the
narrative being put forward by the media
just wait until q anon shows up in
canada though that is going to really be
a game changer because that will show
everyone that this is
uh orchestrated
no i'm joking
i was like wait a minute you know cue
yeah i mean
i'm gonna let you talk i'm gonna let you
say what you have to say enough no
that'll be next it'll be no this is the
canadian queue they've already tried
this is russia propaganda right now
exactly and they've had the confederate
flags and they've had the you know then
they had the they had the informant
there who you know they kicked him out
but pretty soon it's going to be cute
but you know it's going to be
canada queue there will be like
candidates
a lady on tv who was like now because of
canada's support for ukraine do you
think russia could oh my gosh
this is the thing right they only have
so many tricks in their back they're
remarkably uncreative people and the
thing is these tactics have kind of
worked for a little while but more and
more people have been waking up to them
and i think we're finally at the tipping
point where no one believes it anymore
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you